The joe rogan experience.
I,
one of the most uncomfortable moments in my life was me sitting next to Kareem
Abdul Jabbar.
Actually,
I had to wildly uncomfortable moments that involved Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
One is,
he just sat down on my radio show and I was like,
you know,
you never see any,
any guys in their seventies that are over six,
seven or six,
eight.
And I mean I,
you know,
I'm not trying to bring you down you literally,
but is there some syndrome or have you talked to somebody or how does it work?
Cause you just don't see seven footers that are 80 years old but yet you seem
like you're in perfect health and I don't know how it works and if there's
something that I'm not aware of.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
And I was like,
you know how you don't see a lot of old guys?
They're like over six,
five.
They seem to go a little earlier in life.
So my affect,
the little short Jewish guys,
the ones that go on forever,
is there some connection correlation between the height and the short longevity?
And he was like,
I never thought about it.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Really?
And he's like,
yeah,
now I am this kind of comfortable.
Like I was like,
but no,
but I need to bring this up.
So he,
uh,
he did that to me.
And then we're like dodger all star game or something,
celebrity game.
And we're sitting next to each other waiting for the real dodger game to end in
like the,
you know,
the time it was Sorta,
dug out eating hot wings or something like this up on the Lowe's level.
And some kid came by and said,
could you sign my baseball?
And I signed this baseball.
And then he handed it to Kareem Abdul Jabbar and he said,
could you sign my baseball?
And he's like,
uh,
no.
And,
and the kid was like,
really?
Cause it just take a second.
And he's like,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not doing that right now.
And I'm seeing like right next to him.
And the kid comes back for a third,
like Ryan,
and he's like,
you know,
just real quick.
And he's like,
no,
I'm sorry.
Wow.
And I'm like,
just fucking sign it.
Just sign it.
And then he walks away and then his mom shows up like 10 minutes later and she's
like,
I'm so sorry to disturb you,
Mr Abdul Jabbar.
But um,
DePaul for my son,
he's such a huge fan.
Do you think you could just take a moment?
It's like,
sorry.
No.
And she's like,
just,
just a moment and,
and she's like,
no,
thank you.
And I'm just like,
I'm sitting next to him wanting to crawl out of my urethra and just go under the
carpet.
You know that thing,
having to pretend like,
you know,
that body language that says I'm not listening.
Like we can all know the fake body language.
I am listening,
but I'm trying to discover the,
I'm not really listening.
You start leaning a little in God and she really asked like three or four times.
He's like,
sorry.
No.
And she's like,
well,
I'm really,
because we could have signed it in this time.
It took,
no,
I'm sorry.
No,
just like Holly,
I want to go.
I'll fucking sign it.
I'll your pussy whatever.
Please go away with tape.
Thank your son somewhere and then it's fucked up.
He is.
Yeah,
I guess was dead,
right?
No,
no,
no.
The point is,
the point at which will Chamberlain is done.
Yeah,
we'll,
it's dead.
The point,
the point is,
um,
I realize the guy seven four,
there's not a place,
it's,
it's about height.
I mean your spot and you're stopped.
He gets stopped everywhere.
He goes.
I'm not defending the guy,
but that guy has probably been bugged for autographs.
None stop for 50 years.
And I bet he's just fucking hadn't impacted asphalt of it.
Betty has,
but he should reconsider the way that in that case,
especially little kids,
some kid,
and you can make their day.
It's so easy to make their day.
You're going to have to communicate with them and he's right there and you're
sure that I'm preaching to the choir talking to you.
You sure it was him,
right?
It wasn't a guy who just look like,
yeah,
it's a six [inaudible] four black guy changed his name from Lew Alcindor Doula,
who was Lew Alcindor.
Yeah.
I was thinking like I was,
I was joking about this once where I was saying,
you know,
Cat Stevens,
uh,
Cassius clay,
Lew Alcindor all really bitch and names like no reason to take the Muslim name.
It's true.
Trickle should take the Muslim name,
right?
Not maybe even Dick Butkus but not cash is polite like cats.
Steve's like you guys already are.
We're blessed with some of the coolest names on the planet.
You know,
much less pussy.
You're going to get cat.
Steven's going to ease left moves lamb or whatever the fuck it is.
I mean that you're going to cut the pussy spicket off imagining.
Imagine his agent.
How does that Hobos had the phone call go with his agent.
Hey Marty.
Yeah.
No,
I'm not going by cat anymore.
That's uh,
that's my slave name now.
Non Cat Stevens.
Now I'm going to,
now I'm going to be shelling my neck down is going to be the best of Yousef
Islam.
You're a fucking human being.